All right, so let's, let's do a quiz. Give you a
chance to kind of think about what where are these trade-offs are actually
going to be. So we're going to pick the degree for the housing data,
and your choices are going to be the degree zero, one, two, three,
or eight. So a constant, that's the first choice. Or a line
that has some slope that, you know, sort of increases with the
data, that's your second choice. Or it could be we use a
degree two parabola. So sort of goes up and then levels off.
Or you can it might be a little hard to see but here's a cubic that that
goes up flattens out a little bit and then rises up again at the end. Or we
could go with the full monty, the octic.
You can see that might not be spelled correctly.
That actually has enough degrees of freedom that it
can hit each of these points perfectly. Like that.
>> The authority line.
>> [LAUGH] Good, you got that in.